aujourd'hui largo winch est l'un des
hommes les plus puissants de la planète
suite au décès brutal de son père
j'ai décidé de vendre le groupe w le
croque winch est estimée à
approximativement 1 53 milliard de
dollars le produit de cette vente sera
intégralement réinvestis dans un projet
humanitaire
vous allez vous créer de nombreuses
inique la procureur frank n souhaiterais
vous interrogez le sur winch saute au
sujet d'un compte bancaire secret qu'y a
servi à payer un général birman avant
tout il y a trois ans le général bois
aux mines et ses hommes ont détruit le
village de kate vous je vous soupçonne
d'être allé sur ordre de votre père j'ai
vécu parmi les siens pendant des mois
n'avait aucune raison de leur faire du
mal
je ne sais pas ce que tu fuis mais je ne
veux pas fuir avec toi tu croyais que
mon père était capable de choses
pareilles regardez moi le jour même où
j'annonce la création de ma fondation
un procureur débarque chez moi et
m'accuse de crime contre l'humanité
c'est ainsi qu'il considérait théorie du
complot
en conséquence j'ai décidé d'inculper
monsieur largo winch de complicité de
crimes contre l'humanité son action a
cédé 2 27% des pistes
et ce n'est sans doute que le début
herman manipuler la question c'est de
savoir par qui
en tout cas n'est pas complètement tort
vous avez des tas d'ennemis
homme sans amis hommes sont râleurs